[Music]
welcome guys to the string
it's the games of the week today and I'm
going to discuss free games
hopefully the time in there is enough
time for free games if not the oldest
cousin me too but the computer is done
for free games from the only I think
Turner is happening right now in the
world the candidates the only and the
most important tournaments happening so
the candidates have been so many
interesting games currently and two
girls I had hard time too with picking
one I like one from each run because I
the other I would like to cover all of
them but like it's so I mean the time is
limited and all of them are interesting
so I had to basically make some choices
so the first round in the first round
there were tourists to result to result
of games it was wrong how one again he
came against England and the Johnny
Polish g1 against onion theory and said
the game I wanted to talk about a 93 9 f
60 45 93 96 d4c takes d4 Knight takes d4
is six and the onion side up on g3 which
is the most popular debated line
symmetrical English lots of ideas for
both sides
mostly what try to create some very
creative play and this is actually what
onion did in this game Queen b6 90 b5
other there are many possibilities there
is light of three nights e2 i think III
but two main most popular continuations
are 90 b5 93 93 played against
me Lazaro bruising in 2018 and he out
prepared me after 95 for Bishop before
c5 I had to face which is the new day I
wasn't familiar with a play Queen c6 a
free b6 which looks sensible to me
Bishop a4 96 me shop d6 b tech c5 I was
optimistic I have what I have a pawn I'm
just I was just extra pawn but an I
didn't see compensation for him after a
three we should take the free bed we
take C free I have basically only move
in this position and unfortunately I
didn't find it and I got very very
quickly very bad position so I played
Bishop a6 and after Bishop takes a 6
Quint x86 Knight takes e5 2624 my
position just it's very bad therefore
here only move that I believe you had to
play is a5 but I couldn't find it either
I know it so so you know if Sutton was
like a 4 a 5 I are hard to play so this
is one line but it is decided on 90 b5
which 95 Bishop a4 Knight g4 III a6 all
well known h3 8xb 5 h 2 h d4 Knight
takes e4 and he range and his team
probably came up with the novelty of
rook c1 this is very interesting because
I think computers dismiss it immediately
but after if we give them some time they
start figuring out this is actually very
interesting line Quinn betrays the mood
has been played on only so far d5 my
knowledge of this job takes e4 d takes
c4 Queen takes d5 Knight Queen takes me
final text be 5 but this is pretty much
draw it after okay 5 for instance 96
just different color bishops if I let's
say position equal
I don't same problems for black here
that's why Roxy one here is very
interesting move and list very very
unbalanced positions and interesting
play so let's see what happens because
the rest let's say panel seven moves are
pretty much forced from both sides d5
the most natural be free hitting the
Knight Bishop before takes on c4 or gave
three using the pin to get the piece
back we shall be five bringing the
Bishop of the game f6 logical key in the
Bishop Bishop d4 Queen a5 increasing the
tension c3 we shall be to developing the
bishop and finishing the development we
shall take c3 and right now only move
rook takes c3 rook takes c3 and King f1
and basically this is nearly all forced
it is an only move king of one and I
gave it an exclamation mark simply
because it just looks nice however it
only move so that actually doesn't maybe
you deserve the exclamation mark but
it's anyway nice because right now black
has huge choice and all of the lines
basically lead to crazy positions were
probably onion was very well prepared
but I'm not entirely sure whether he was
prepared very well against before
because this would never played and
onion started to think so let's see
quickly let's look at briefly other
possibilities that were the black head
in the position let's say B takes e4
which is also logical take the pawn
let's say g5 short Castle G takes f6
also it's possible to take on backing g2
and something like this could have been
onions analysis couldn't be won protects
the free takes takes takes H season here
any root x h6 is a draw somehow you look
at five rupees should have five some
equal position let's say we just rogue
f7 or also if I was possible yeah if I
was stronger so it's some very messy
position and Nathan the white can hope
for something here other possibility is
detective six rook takes f6 out of
southern because detective 6 mission h5
probably of protect following Quincy
Forbes very
Duras we shot xf6 detectives Kim G -
which looks very very unclear but we're
open c3 and kink on Jade so exports
exposed so much I don't think like what
is in much danger even though what black
is two pawns up so also quimby one could
be an idea sometimes here so I think
black is the black is more I mean white
does have doesn't risk anything and
black needs to be very careful here so
this could have been an analysis all
possible movie through text c4b should
repeal taxi for would-be taxi for and
here g5 again and this leads to some
crazy lines that can happen that can
happen let's say if 5g takes f6 text on
d4 text on g7 Ruby g8 Queen h5 in here
black basically we've only moved
according to my analysis because I
looked at it can make a draw but finding
it all over all funny almost line over
the board is not an easy task task and
definitely this was what ang and his
team had in mind basically such both is
very hard to meet over the board what
preparation that it's very easy to go
wrong so let's say kinky 7 Queen g5 can
get Queen e5 some money checks which six
were interesting move Queen d8 and here
somehow black can manage the escape for
a draw but never played before here and
this move is the most natural I really
like it so the idea is if Bishop takes
c3 be taxi free responsive human baby
release trunk so only move basically
provides to create some attack on the
key on black skin sub G v e5 again the
most natural reply hitting the Bishop
Bishop takes c3 B takes c3 again and
right now which takes f6 the most
natural again and here young new
palmistry play detective six which in
mapping is a mistake simply after G
takes f6 white can hope for some
advantage but unleash went wrong
immediately he play okay let's see first
what black could do and here is one of
the typical positions were basically
material
is less important rather than pieces
activity and kink safety
so therefore black was supposed to play
short castle basically hiding the King
on a king side even though we still
expose but at least the rubies in the
game so basically two factors and this
is keeping the equality for instance
there is linac f2 x g7 King takes g7
Bishop d3 h6 nothing nothing happens
queen h5 looks very natural hitting on
g6 on h6 but Rock f6 cool defense
nothing happens Queenie 5 and NFC - we
should take c2 Queen d2 and I think that
Y has nothing more than just a draw here
repetition Queen seven recursive and
queen e5 rook f6 and because it's
hanging on c2 hanging on f2 and so
probably just a draw so this was the way
to play basically with y it would with
black short castle and the ignore the
material deficit and just go for the
activity however Napoli GTX of says
which is the most natural move you know
takes takes and see what happens
at least with some problems after if I
played CD 5 for instance it would be
very very unpleasant I think for black
to face this position because white just
needs to play King g2 and King is safe
and the rook on the first run covers
everything couldn't be free follows I
think was just study better here let's
say let's see Queen c5 which should be
free King g7 Queen b3 and now Kim G -
Roxy one follows
black has to do something very very
quick and concrete in her tomb try to
make maintain balance otherwise will be
just much better other post other movies
Queen takes a two but this Queen a
textbook may may be made by Queens the
freakin c2 and Kim G - and again Roxy -
works one is coming and
Black's king is in danger I think what
is just better here
therefore Queen but on each play Queen B
1 which is very mysterious to me like
understand it on each seventh King II
but if you want to take the pawn back
why just not take the pawn the d5 pawn
it was just central pawn you just keep
all the options in in hand and you know
it just seems much more natural just
grab the five phone but he decided
nevertheless on Queen B 1 which is very
mysterious to me and he fell only 6
minutes which is even more mysterious
because in such position playing Queen B
1 it seems like Virge if ok was winning
then it's great I like doesn't he's not
winning then you know you shouldn't do
it so queasy 7 very natural reply quindi
3 against it XD 5 could have been done
by B by C 2 response the C 1 is very
very strong so quindi free hitting on C
free right now
nappa played very strong B 5 basically
building up the center because CX defies
met by or C decks defies meant by C 2
and this one's unstoppable and 25 also
runs into C 2 because Kim G - Bishop e7
therefore Queen takes c3 B takes c4 and
only basically way to protect - you know
I mean sort of maintain balance
relatively because already black is
slightly better author of the realm of
Queen B want to infrequent b1 the only
move to try to maintain bias here is to
play effort to break the pawn chain and
this is what I need it very very well d
takes e4 gauge for correct because if
quiz c4 just takes takes Bishop g4
back is just pawn up only black can win
this and why this force to basically
defend for very very long long time I
don't think it's a nice deep position to
defend especially with four versus two
on a King side I have four gauge for
Bishop e6 rook takes the e for taking
the pawn a short castle and right now is
the critical position
where
I think uh nish
I think went wrong he could have played
through Kate
okay maybe not really wrong which this
moon was heavily criticized by
commentators as far as I looked at but
I'm I think after this move he's
basically forced to like like long term
defendants and he cannot win for sure
the world was better to play here a map
in his luggage for basically this move
yes he's wide spawn down but still
blacks King is more exposed and rather
than White's King pawn on c4 is still
blocked it maybe so some object of an
attack and wife is still a pawn which
can move forward and deflect blacks
forces from supporting the c4 pawn which
may lead to let's say some drawers and
games also this possibility of creating
a attack on a web blacks King trying to
make a draw by some perpetual so this
was I think the best for instance Roxy a
kim jiwon kim 7a for I don't really see
how white can black can continue here
there's also ideas for G Bishop g4 poem
c4 it's week rather than strong right
now so I think black-white has enough
compensation here
however on each play Bishop takes c4
which is very dubious move hover is not
losing as many people claim but
definitely his fourth right now to
defend till the end of the game
so King gsturm is very very strong King
h8 would be wrong because between d3
Bishop a5 Queen f3 and senator Cohen f8
is under attack and relative to position
of King on g7 if Queen d3
Bishop a5 a queen a freed doesn't lead
anywhere because we're gonna fight this
is just protected so Bishop f5 is just
pinning and black wins therefore queen
bee free rook b8 hitting the queen and
right now I don't see any other move
then Bishop takes DC just give the Queen
back let me just give the Queen and then
I get Rock and Bishop and try to hold
this end game which is hard to defend
but it I've in my opinion is defendable
but not unfortunately the way
did it because at some point he just
went wrong
Bishop takes six rook takes be free rock
g4 check so it's okay to fall in this
check King evade Bishop takes be free
Quincy one King G to Quincy six you just
kim jiwon H five and this is in this
position as far as I checked unusual
here four minutes while you an apology
had 17 minutes in this position
Anish made a losing mistake my opinion
because he gave rubgy check and this
group doesn't really belong here and
this is the position where basically you
should start thing about fortresses and
if you think like about fortress is just
the only move that comes the best move
sort of like the only / best I don't
know how to pull it but the move that
was - had to be played basically is
repaid for by keeping the rook on H on
the on H form namely on for Frank it's
very hard for white - for black to
create to make progress and to create
sort of a passed pawn or I know no we
can White's King or made make some pawn
break flow while after up g8 h4 very
often while my black Everton my play h4
in the grave two versus one on Ian F
files and so it is sort of like
problematic so therefore a row gauge for
Athene is just draw I mean it should be
a draw let's say if Queen f3 just Bishop
to c4 Bishop comes to f1 even though if
even if the a pawn will be lost which I
don't think would it be even like
necessarily the case because I can play
for any moment we've broken it for
covering it and I don't think white
should have many difficulties with
making draw here and after if for
basically trying to break the structure
of e3
back in just what can just take the pawn
take another pawn Queen f3 and right now
we're okay Jade and Ruby g8 just
covering on g3 and I don't see a way to
make progress for for black so I think
it's just a draw
but on each play Luke g8 which is a
mistake properly time time travel he
made this mistake with g7 king g6 raw
page 7 hitting this h5 form but right
now Queen f3 and it's looking very
promising for black if free fe4 III is
coming through graduate before exactly
roopd 8 king g7 Bishop d1 quincy free
room d5 and now h 4 verse from move GTX
h4 and right now black achieve the
exactly the same the position that they
wanted and right now the the past if
black can basically push the F pawn
forward this just came over like if the
pawn comes to a 4 or afraid basically
there is nothing white can do but there
are still some technical difficulties
and actually Yanni Palmas chip
unfortunately for him blow it here
because he played at 5 and Chris head
was the best move as far as I checked
because it frightens Queen g8 and also
the ferns a5 a5 a4 and and so on sort of
and this is this I think is winning
because white lacks coordination and
looks just bad for for for while I don't
know how to how to defend it or not to
be honest if a5 can have 6 of 4 comes
just looks just like game over so but he
played a 5 and this gave onions a great
chance to make a draw and he took it but
then he went wrong again unfortunately
for him look at 5 Queen e1 Kim G - King
with the Queen D 1 or g5 and even though
black got the bishop it's just a dead
draw with correct play because rook
comes to g3 as our indicates and I don't
see how to make a progress QF with black
Queen a1 happened
rook g4 Queen B 1 a rogue g3 just
quintics a two row gauge 3 and the thing
is if but there are still some tricks is
it is a drop of there are still some
tricks if only White's King can go to e
1
or e2 and Brooke who remains on the
third rank it's just the drawer there is
no break for test for sure
however keep on g2 there are some ideas
for black and is not so trivial and
young I put some very practical problems
for Anna SH and eventually he managed to
trick him somehow so let's see how he'd
managed to do it
25 King f1 Queen D 1 correct queen g4
group G free right now Queen h4 seems
like the most natural but after King f1
King comes there's no way of stopping
King coming to e 2 and E 1 and this is
just draw under if the King wouldn't
come to the if the king is not coming to
e 2 or e 1 then black is winning and
this is actual happened again so we'll
get to this position later and this and
we'll see how Jung won this game because
this is exactly the how you should win
this with black rook a 325 kim ji-won
king f6 ruby free just lots of
maneuvering and trying to trick your
opponent 25 king f1 Queen d2 those of
basically trying to confuse her open
rather than the comment come of the
ideas UFC through cage free and here I
think that is simplest was rookie free I
don't see anything wrong with just king
a fight with G free just coming back
hitting only 4 as well and this looks
dry which to me but rogue h3 allows King
g6 King H 5 and this I'm not sure okay
it still should be a draw but it's a
little bit tricky already still rock if
free was the best defense just getting
this pawn king h5 rook takes e4 and as I
checked with table beta it is a draw
probably still tricky but it is a draw
so I will claim this is a draw
Ruby g3 is all right still but
after King h5 finally again rook if we
you have to go because if King h4 rook
takes e4 is at the drop there is a way
to what can win black inaudible black
can win this without the pawn on e4 and
if Queen B 1 and then 0 h3 and it's hard
to make progress but this is important
position to room
because after okay a disposition of rook
h3 is a is a draw but with white to play
it is winning for white and this is why
rook h3 queen bee one is a sucked funk
it's brilliant move by Napo and it hooks
funk suddenly there is no way to for
white to make a drop anymore because if
what gives the h4 pound then while gives
the spawn and the king is not coming to
e2 or e1 and if and there's no other
move basically because King rook h2
looks awful just kimchi for probably
weighs kimchi frequency whereas the
residue Quinn g1 queen [ __ ] to present
queen of wander by still basically no
move and the free lose of course too
many moves but here is one of them so
yeah only move here was rookie free twin
porn rock h3 and idea being that after
King is for just are pushing the pawn
and keep the rook remains on h3 and it's
probably still a drop but after row
gauge Freitas is funny a loss lost 4 4 4
4 honest because because you just drop
this Punk will be free cage for and
let's see how this is winning basically
the king he tries to cut cut blacks King
out on the Drake file but you can do it
forever
lukkage freaking g4 and basically right
now King blacks King comes to d4 Queen
comes to d3 and this is just winning and
let's see exactly Queen d3 and this is
game over because after root XD free it
takes D 3 and D pawn just promise to the
Queen and this is where onion resigned
so it was very interesting game with
lots of ideas for both sides both
defensive in the endgame for white ideas
of fortress and
also how black can put some pressure and
I'm even in rows in end games like Napa
did and interoperating was very
interesting as well so it was very in
general was very eventful game so I'm
glad that we could see that in in
candidates because it's one of the most
important tournaments in a year so
seeing some players playing like that is
definitely entertaining and you can
always learn from that so let's see
another game I want to talk about the
other one was a little bit more
positional this was a Vassar like graph
much maxilla graph versus Dingley run
and here we have seen other loss
bitingly run in this tournament because
in the first round he lost to walk how
e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6 big glaring
specialty open spanish slash real Lopez
name it the way we want a six Bishop a4
9 f6 castle and we should be seven Rogge
one we should be free be fab you should
be free short castle and see free defy
would see if we would have been met with
d5 which Dingley run employed many many
times lately and if a for ahsha
Edmund I played this against England in
2019 in March and I the great chances to
win this game but it was eventually a
draw I play the game was before a 5d 6d
three Bishop e6 take I took only six and
this structure I had some chances to win
and but eventually it was a drop
mashaallah graph decided to play h3
which should be 73 and this is consider
usually harmless line for black simply
because of the d5 line that the black
has here and there are several
this is usually considered as the best
approach if you can go d5 you should go
t5 here in Spanish in such structures so
let's see what happens he takes d5
Knight takes d5 but this is not what
Dingley rounded and we'll see why he may
not have done that in a second night xe5
is one of the possibilities and the main
move and here we have the the theory had
the in theory there is the very
important for the theory if I here is
basically a Kuryakin
Karlsson a game from 2016 the match and
it was 94 and let's see how the game
went on Knight c3 Knight before Bishop
f4 Knight xb3 8xb 3f c 594 f6f-3 f5 and
base I've I remember correctly Cara
Carson was playing a very very fast
process all preparation and he just made
drawn in red by forest so he and so
Knight g5 Bishop to g5 not Iguchi v h6
9625 a free rook e8 rookie 526 c3 takes
takes takes Texan before Texan before
and if I remember correctly he was still
like in preparation and actually the
game ended in a draw here very quickly
the true Kashiwa Roxy a just trading the
rooks Queen e1 trading everything and
draw this is what I agree to a draw and
so this is one line that is possible but
there is there also other resistance if
reason Reed dangerous I can pluck and
just take a play Bishop f6 defend the
pawn Knight d2 allows 94 which is not
desirable I think for white and the main
sort of alternative is a 4 and this is
what happened in things game 2017 versus
event record which he lost which is
probably the reason why he doesn't want
to go anymore for d5 my guess I'm not
sure about that but I guess what does
well I'm guessing and the game happened
94 takes takes apex d5 it takes b5 rook
takes Bishop takes a 893 Bishop before
Bishop d2 Bishop takes the - quinta XD -
and now Queen f6
if before let's say night see for now
see 595 looks a little bit unpleasant
for black because of this pressure on f7
from Bishop embouchure and I'd only 5
Queen f6 Knight Bishop takes d5 Bishop
takes d5 Knight takes d5 usually takes
g2 is all force basically line King to
SG to Quincy six King gauge to a queen
b5 and queen of four and these positions
are unequal but involves positions very
often white can put some pressure simply
because it's a little bit easier to play
and polls on d4 and c7.r could be
sometimes wake and what is important
many times rock and games are very
dangerous for black so let's forest for
instance Queen B - Queen c7 and it was
even truck versus - dink a queen before
would be for g6
King G to H 5 c4 suddenly he missed this
move and 24 is just surrounded and just
lost and was lost very soon not me - he
played like still some moves but it was
very dangerous suddenly and clearly what
was in charge here in this game
eventually even took one another
possibility is at stake here
Queen C 5 and this Queen e5 here is
dangerous for a 4-ply because if tried
this is just much better for white this
pawns are most likely going to fall rook
c5 Kim G freaking a for kinky 4 and so
on if Queen b6 just be free
c5 rookie for and white has some
pressure here by 74 or some idealized my
page for each 5 but with correct play
black should eventually make a draw but
this is most likely why in my opinion a
dink then
want to go for this those lines and
that's why he declined the hidden would
play d5 and he played these things which
is much more positional especially if he
maybe didn't remember some lines you
know and we apply this very quickly so
he might have not to remember some lines
and they want to go into them without
memory without having to memorize and
here just decide to play something more
solid which is perfectly understand wa
product so d6 a frequency 7h c free rook
f e8 Bishop d2 and right now he played
typical maneuver in this type of
structures 98 Knight comes to e6 but
this had to be anticipated by MVL
because he play 95 and for sure was his
preparation and right now black faces
some unpleasant choice because if Bishop
takes d5 it takes d5 for instance why
just has pair of bishops and slightly
better position it just as simple as
that
if Knight takes d5 is what happens in
the game is what happened the game and
after Knight takes d5 it takes d5 basic
Nevin da B should be something a little
bit out of the game and blacks facing
still some issues but if Knight is 6 and
if 96 then black gives away the pair of
bishops which should be was for in
whites favor to have the pair of Bishops
advantage but so this is some unpleasant
choice here for for black from practical
point of view and
in my opinion the best way to react to
this line to this move 95 was anyway to
just give away the pair officials with
knife 96 even I take C 7 Queen Texas 7
basically the post the most the the
thing is that pawn structure is still
balanced and after and in that position
is closed so the pair of bishops the
hundreds of pair of bishops for what is
you don't will not be felt as much as it
would be in a completely open position
so 95 for instance I analyzed takes
takes h6 for instance in Bishop h4 g5
Bishop g3 and c5 and here I've drove
arrows some possible plans for for black
we should be a DB should be six month
plan one plan on the plans King just
honking just ignite h5 basically black
is playing against Bishop on g3 which
being completely kind of like out of the
game for now gives black you know
relative balance the relative to what
happened in the game it's definitely
much better will happen in the game even
though what Kubasaki better is not so
bad for black other possibilities Bishop
d2 but this is just c5 rook c8 see for
these bishops are not doing much in
their way and visual texture sig gives
away the pair of bishops and some
tactical ideas will rookie free Andrew
get free doesn't really don't really
work because which pigeon comes to e6
and everything is perfectly fine for
black that's why this was I think the
correct approach to play just 96 and try
to maybe definitely with the world's
position but still perfectly defendable
because after Knight takes d5 it takes
d5 and those pieces are
998 mission b7 are misplaced and their
source of all problems black is facing
here and as we have seen in the game as
we know the result
ding clearin unfortunately for him made
I mean make me like basically it was
this plus this pleasure basically in
tour free moves which is surprising
because position seaming is seemingly
equal maybe was slightly better but like
losing in three moves or four moves is
sounds crazy so let's see what he did
what he could have done better and in
the board to understand here that this
picture won't be seven is really a
problem and you need to activate this
Bishop so the first move that he played
c5 is wrong because it doesn't challenge
this pawn on d5 and after c5 disponible
mission becomes useless sort of
therefore the only way to play here was
to play c6 and after see four take on d5
take on d5 and now play f6 because f5 is
a mistake because not xe5 there is takes
tactical trick detects d5 d6
are discovered track taking the pair of
bishops opposition's opened what is our
more active definitely black is having
real real issues for instance King h8
takes on seven through p7 and d4 for
instance opening up to position and
black is definitely struggling here also
the res move like bishops III Bishop
before there many many moves before is
one of them Bishop g5 as well as
possible while is clearly better but
it's not a five out of six is more much
much more solid an idea of nine f7 it's
not so easy for white to prove how big
of an advantage White has definitely
what is better because of this Bishop
won't be 78 still being misplaced but
the way how I mean it's not easy to
prove
white advantage I looked a little bit
and I for the first sensible not if
seven bishops if reroute Bishop d8 when
the free Bishop e6 but this looks
playable this look is just playable for
both sides and I think may avoid a study
pair is only
avoids bear is only very slightly and
in the long run you know black can can
equalize and maybe if what over pushes
something let's say if what takes on e5
the knight can come take only five be
shown mr. big will be very strong it can
go either way so it was the way to play
for black even though I believe why
still study better is not so clear how
to proceed at least over the board so
this was the way to play because c5
right now a four and this Bishop is
never coming to back to the game
basically this pond if I was restricting
it and I don't II eight also is not
going anywhere for now and right now
ding Liron played another move which
basically it's a crucial mistake and
it's just put explosion just collapsing
which is insane sort of because his loss
already on move number 15 but it's very
instructive what he could have done
better here he played at five which is a
terrible move and he realized for sure
that he's not on the edges very bad he
is to improve it but the the way he's
done it is very bad because he has to
play here f6 and the point being that FC
is just much more solid move and put
keeps kind of like more soil only five
and the knight of seven next it's not
easy to I mean it's much more solid
simply so here the problem we have five
that the very often there could be some
Knight takes d5 and d6 ideas and that's
the big problem because after a five I
mean after f6 a bab the rook takes
Bishop takes a eight let's say c4 and
right now there is move like rook f8 for
instance it's only move it'll only move
but basically this diagonal here this
diagonal here is very annoying it with
those pieces here and basically black
black group needs to go to a paid in
order to
not to be lost basically or pawn before
to be lost so Luke f8 is the only move
and relative and in the same position by
pulling f5 we would just have what
happen in the game
after a city could be five Quint XB v
into the same position but points on b5
on a5 there is simply Knight takes e5
and white just wins white just wins
because there is 95 tactics and the game
over and we will see this in a second
when the ones we move to a five line but
just wanted to see how white can try to
win in this in this position Bishop c4
for instance and it's interesting pawn
sacrifice because if white if black I
mean is in time to consolidate the
pieces Knight f7 bring the rook bring
the bishop back to the same beasts be a
b7 c87
things like this maybe Bishop to d8 c 7
as well suddenly black would be fine and
most this pawn structure for what is not
perfect either so in very very long run
a white can find itself in trouble but
of course tactically and considering how
bad most pieces are fisherman 7 as well
is not great and queen with eyes exposed
as well turns object of an attack
immediately which the next bishop c4
white can exert a huge pressure on black
so let's see what can happen Bishop c4
for instance Queen c2 is also possible
what could it be a little bit slow
because suddenly it's hard to proceed
with white and blacks position is quite
solid Bishop c4 just maybe Queen b6
maybe also queenie 8 and then we should
be 6 it's not so easy to proceed with
with with white so I'm a pinion
Bishop c4 is very interesting and strong
approach Queen a1 even trading Queens
because it's correct because
this both pieces are certainly misplaced
Queen a1 rugae 1 let's say Bishop d7
Luke a7 and Bishop a5 next it's very
it's just very problematic possibly just
by this part isn't the verge of winning
here soap Queen PA let's say work be one
Queen c8 Queen a7 Bishop a5 and White
has some pressure however o or Queen b6
actually quim C is more accurate because
after Bishop I father quick Queenie 8
and we don't want to allow that but
Queen b6 let's say bishop a 8 or ok one
comes to a 7 y has long lasting pressure
and it's not easy to play this with
black so this was supposed this is what
dinkler had to go for even though is
maybe not fun but this is the only way
to basically play this because after 5/8
X b5 is exactly the same lines but with
the difference points on the 556 and
this is to huge disadvantage for King
Lear and Luke they said Bishop takes 8
and c4 and suddenly I was shocked when I
looked at it but basically what is just
winning there is no defense for black
just on defense and the pawn is lost
because of this diagonal basically
involves two diagonals this diagonal and
this diagonal while it's just winning a
material here and we will see in this in
a second let's say we should be texting
for Bishop a4 came over
Bishop d7 seat XB v just means the pawn
queen text before Bishop a4 and if
Bishop a white
I'm sorry rook a fight it's text b5
Quinn text b5 and night xe5 and this
what I said earlier if F pawn will never
fix this wouldn't be possible but in
here is just wins on the spot basically
if he takes e5 d6 with cover check
hitting on his 7 game over
so here ding Lorentz airplane I have 7
which is basically his last hope but
position just lost because it takes b5
Queen B 5 bishop i form that's it and he
pet tried to create some King side
attack but it doesn't work just
knowledge to Kim G 7 Bishop c4 and the
rest is just nice technique by MVL I
always just see how the game ended g4 9
h6 Queen f3 Bishop d8 Queen G to F 4
okay if you have to go a 4 here because
we were King was also weak with this
maneuver
Kim G 6 by the way Kim sang kinases can
be questioned but positions either way
lost so he at least trying to do
something maybe want to play h5
so he strangled his dad but g4 just
texted also away so I just completed
winning for white a for because some
doors some issues with Knight f3 maybe a
a fork just before 24 9 like coming
tonight it's coming to f3 and this is
beautiful picture beautiful position for
for white but ugly I create incredibly
ugly for for black so yeah this is just
completely lost and the game lasted 7 or
8 more moves let's see how it ended I
give the 6th night b7 and Bishop a5 4
pieces are all collapsing this the pin
on B file a night on d8 is hit by this
Bishop there is no way black can save
the material save the peace so lingering
resigned so I don't think this game was
given so much credit as far as to my
knowledge list but I think it's very
instructive and the way
the England lost this it's very very
interesting because you don't expect to
lose in Spanish after being lost after
15 moves basically in such a quiet line
like h3t freaky lost so quickly that is
just astonishing mapping so yeah the
obit is a little bit for this game and I
think we have also time for the next
next one because it was please one was
pretty short but nevertheless
interesting save it
let's see the last game which is Dingley
run where he is struck back at vs
Fabiano Fabiano being a leader before
his game him
unfortunately for for him he lost even
though but but the game was extremely
complicated and extremely interesting so
let's see what happened d4 d5 c4 c6
Knight f3 Knight f6 Knight c3 dis txt
for I don't think Fabiano played this
earlier or like the plate is like so
often for sure it was part of his
preparation for the candidates a for
Bishop f5 95 e 6 the other line possible
is 1997 Knight takes e4 and now Europe
knight Knight b6 95 or and a5 and the
right now why has variety of choices
there is a free move which is which is
very positional a free also positional
of annex e 4 and very aggressive moves
like h4 which has came to popularity by
Anton gorev off in 2000 and we want to
mess it up but like a fetus in for tin
also the nice his metonym plated I'm
holding myself twice h4 and in 2015
however and
with decent results so this is one line
another line is here possibly with Queen
c7 which which leads to jiff after which
every fact a very complicated tragic
play where why this hope why this is
considered a slightly better but black I
think it's relatively soit as well
so but II six line is another line
possible and this leads to much more
concrete play and in general I think
Fabiano shows shows with this move that
he's not going for draws for dual
drawers he's just going for win every
game which is really nice to see if as a
spectator and of this tournament and to
see so much fighting chess this game he
lost the straw but like the way he
played it is very entertaining and also
top level basically just I mean he he's
going for it and if he keeps playing
like this even though he lost today but
the way act the activity is presenting
and you for sure do well in this
tournament so a free Bishop takes Bishop
before Knight takes e4 Castle King f2
and the King f2 is aligned is nothing
nothing new I think honestly the king of
two was first time or like Grandmaster
at least first time played by onions
Gary in 2009 so really long time ago
balance I'm sorry Grandmaster back then
and I think it was also annotated some
yearbook or something like this long a
long time ago I saw this like really
long time ago and it is very interesting
line but here they're both has black has
lots of choices after see file there is
9b d7 moves Bishop d6 h6 many many moves
but Fabiano came a his team most likely
came of the novel to e5 and this is I
never seen his move in my life before I
I looked at my analysis I had like like
seven or eight moves or maybe
for back but if I was none of them above
hover all analysis but still if I was
just novelty almost number nine and it's
very hard to meet because King f2 of
course is over the idea of playing
before and trying to build a strong
Center but with amid if five black
certainly want to create some pressure
in the center and make use of this King
expose kinguin f2 so there are lots of
choices here for white and black and I
want to dive in theoretical you know
discussion about this this if I've move
because possibly there will be lots of
new games coming in and after this game
and we will just have to see how the
theory develops I have to my analysis
I'm unless cube very briefly detects if
597 already after the game and this
seems completely unclear to me because
let's say Bishop e6 without nakida
non-designers if we're taking back only
five Lukas just fine and if King gonna
also Queen h4 is afraid right now so
this looks ok for black my opinion also
if for as possible but this it takes d4
Knight a2 we should see v b4 b5 looks
least some wild chess and some analysis
but I don't want to dive into this but
just some wild positions that completely
new and I'm certain that from Fabian his
team will work were well prepared in
this was lines just shows that he's
going for winning every game which is
very good approach that takes e5
happened the game Bishop c2 and quintic
c2 obviously this fall by is my white
point XD for and regaining the piece and
the pond and with King on f2 black is
just better my opinion Queen d2 only
move technically
c5 again hitting the center very
concrete this is basically modern chess
you just can't go I mean like you don't
you don't waste time for like random of
it just very play very concretely it's
just the way in computer error
you sort of need to play chess basically
it's everything is just converted
concrete and right now
I was wondering actually whether if free
move okay basically the ignorant played
d5 and I was wondering whether III would
be maybe a little bit safer however this
pose and inner just you know stabilize
the center develop the bishop maybe hide
the King on a king-sized finally and
still blackness to the result the
problem with the bishop on c2 and
honestly I have no idea was this
position I have certainly no idea black
has so many moves that I try to analyze
some of them but it's such messy
positions just hard for instance Bishop
g6 I for this descent the five nine bt 7
mb d7i batiste Knight xd7 Bishop e2 and
I thought rook c8 with c4 it leads to
some compensation whether it's enough or
not I have no idea possibly I mean looks
definitely very practical for black to
go for it especially if white that Don
doesn't know the the you know was the
evaluation here and what's the what are
the best moves
because even if or see for the nice if I
didn't be free is possible
also if if for than c4 and also there
are some ideas of a 5 which is benoni
like if King 1 f2 is definitely not fun
to play with white so I thought this
could be you know part of his
preparation performance preparation CD
is possible but it probably is slightly
better position however I'm not sure
what this also king is on f2 exposed
White has pair of bishops true about
positions opened so anything can happen
Bishop e3 is also possible 93 96 some
very messy position so the theory as I
said probably will develop around here
especially after this game so d5
happened in the game
Bishop b3 and MacAvoy was suggesting
initially we should be for here which
basically you can take the ideas that
you can't take only for because Knight
takes e4 and the white/black way is the
queen
all actually if I think about bishops
III is the more accurate move which is
TV is definitely more accurate Quincy
394 and BC all same thing and otherwise
we'll just take the piece so this is
just meaning because after Knight takes
e4 actually there could be Knight takes
e4 and this could be also powerful black
but not as better as the other as the
alternative of Bishop takes c3 anyway
here buff to Bishop before g4 is very
strong and this is what computer
realizes after only only after some time
and right now black is facing g5 next
and suddenly is not easy to react to
this move and what is much better
however position still remains very very
unclear and anything can happen
technically so Bishop e3 e4 rook e8
Queen f4 and right now
c4 fabulous turn his preparation which
is amazing 9b d7 I Batista if Knight bTW
7:00 that night beat takes the certain
ethics decided we should be 5 bodies
which has much better
where is development already trading
some pieces which is good considering
the Lord's King has export and exposed
and the White has white is pawn up so
trading pieces in White's favor because
decreases the attacking potential for
for the side of this pawn down for
bragging mean means in in here I'm just
try it just try to generalize so see for
Fabian tries look for contra play active
counter play Knight 64 9 bt7 we shall be
free just trying to cover this diagonal
on c5 you see a 7 and g1p service file
would be always an annoying check and
here this is the first Greek opposition
I thought because here not h5 is
possible Queen 825 9 F 6 and hard to
come up with a move for white because of
course what can repeat with Queen f4
which probably will have that to a draw
if Fabiana walnut but psychologically it
may not have been the greatest idea
because it's kind of like a sign of
weakness
maybe and if you are going for such line
with black and you are definitely trying
to win you are not trying to make a drug
here so we could be I think the
glitterin who lost first two games would
we have been feeling maybe a little bit
comforted because if I can put it like
this simply because he can at least make
a draw in such crazy position against
Fabiano who is so well-prepared so heavy
mind that he can make a draw already or
try to look for something more it's kind
of like confirming fall in my opinion so
for instance I cried to come up with
some lines here and the 592 is decent g5
Bishop takes d5 and some computer
analysis
I assume that Tech 95 zone option
because rook takes if free will happen
and this King is so exposed must be bad
kingi one Bishop Knight I mean h5 queen
of 2a Bishop e6 and this is some
completely unclear position because King
on g1 is yes it's hidden but Reuben h1
is still not in the game
black on is is pawn down to pawns on but
only a pawn down and this looks just
like a mess I have no idea what
disposition just happens completely
unclear but just the fact that he could
have repeated here if Queen a4 is just
kind of like a sign of weakness
this is why my defied I really like the
decision here and for sure was still
preparation for Fabiana but just kind of
like saying from my perspective Knight
a5 Bishop d4 natural move here on f6 and
some lines strength in the center I'm
finding in the center 96 not possible
cause Bishop takes f6 and right now is
the first position that basically I was
kind of confused when I look at it with
the computer as well and here I my
opinion
Fabiano went wrong I say I'm gonna say
it very very cautiously
simply because he played very quickly as
I checked he did but any moment any I
can even
in a minute I think and he assumed he
was in preparation by playing ig6 but I
am Not sure I'm just not sure because
what I noticed that after 96 ok Ford
England play Queen at 5:00 and this is
fine for black but there is a reply for
4y that I found myself Rea very very
hard to meet Quincy one and I don't know
what Fabiano's files stalkers say about
this move but in my opinion this looks
ok so of course welcome computer like
computer risky move but I don't know how
to face it basically because 92 is a
Fred 92 is a threat and it seems to me
that none of the sacrifices only 45
really work maybe I missed something if
I didn't I'm very sorry and but I don't
know I hope we will maybe here somehow
we have some feedback about this but as
for us I checked white is just here
much better for instance I looked at
subsidized like we should take C for
Bishop takes e4 rooks see it just Bishop
b5
let's save rookie 7 just call move like
this just fell to t1 was simply winning
and if Knight takes e4 some crazy stuff
like this
dropped a c4 I can't just give the Queen
back rook takes one rock text one Queen
h4 king he frequented for King D free
and suddenly King is Stefan d3 and there
is no follow-up for blacks attack this
is what I was thinking was analyzed
briefly but still if Knight xe4 here F
takes e4 rook c8 92 we should takes d5
calm quindi one of course passion is
crazy but Khan Queen d1 was so sort of
sealing the deal we should be free just
winning piece up and I didn't see any
conversation for black and the rook c8
92 Bishop takes d5 it takes d4 Knight
takes d5 tonight be free and here again
looks very dangerous for white but again
I couldn't find anything that would be
satisfactory and kind of justifying lack
of a piece so for instance this this
this route d1 didn't see any follow up
so I have no idea what could have been
preparation by Fabian after Quincy won
but I had hard time trying to figure out
what's going on there
what could have been his idea hopefully
there is something and hopefully I'm
wrong but we we will I guess we will see
maybe he sent me in the conference press
conference but I didn't watch it so
maybe my bad I didn't watch it but still
I had hard time explaining hard time
figuring out what could have been his
early after Quincy won their flu that
being said I thought there's always
alternative rook c8 it suggested was
suggested by my engine and they was
leading to huge complications as
positions just so crazy that like
probably black can equalize here let's
take 93 night h5 and the queen g4 if
Queen at five Black is fine after g6 and
there's some entertaining line 94 of
course detective C is made by food
additives mate
therefore f6 Knight f6 and King f7 and
black simply takes the bishop the knight
on f6 and with three pawns for a night I
mean maybe white still can hold but
having the skin exposed on f2
I think it's easier to play with black
rather than with white but positions
pretty much I'm clear but I like blacks
chances that autumn trying to say
there's our move Queen g4 which is
better move and now Knight is six and
this is just extremely messy position
and anyone basically anything can happen
and there's possibility of just making a
draw we should be 595 be shot before but
maybe both sides have nothing better
because D takes is six leads to some
crazy position like this and without
dark square bishop it could be very
risky for for white as well so I don't
know it's just so messy position and I
think Roxy was the better move simply
then rather than wood Fabian played 96
but maybe fabulous files say something
else
and I'm apologize if it's the case but I
just couldn't find refutation of Queen
over like solution to Quincy one but a
dingo Graham played very quickly
Queen a5 and here I really really like
actually no hold on one second the
bishop taxi for Bishop taxi for is
correct 27 and here I
like this for black relatively if not be
free because be free is I think the move
that is leading to whites advantage
however it's very scary move to play and
it understandable the ding leader I
wanted to play something more safe
seemingly say like we should be to sort
of like closer tech kinks or stabilizing
and I like be free living this dynasty
finish up before very loose and possibly
he could have calculated Bishop c5 roopd
one night rookie five Queen h3 rook age
five point two three Bishop d6 you know
this looks just like lose lose just lost
for for white if only there was not much
more like if five and this is linked to
again massive complications where white
is ending up with better chances but
position
what finding it all over the board is
just crazy it's just very hard
especially the feel like you know
already twenty minutes here and Fabian
had like one hour 15 or something I
remember correctly so Bishop takes d5
Bishop takes e5 if visual text e5 then
Bishop to c5 Knight takes okay ain't
night the Senate xe5 just King g1 and
suddenly what is just pawn up black
maybe can take this pawn back but on c4
within this line because on h2 is
hanging but this is please for OKC one
looks just awful for black because put
this exponents just come like completely
crushing Brooke on a Travis misplaced
there are ideas of night be 590 590 for
discovering discover attacked for on the
Queen looks just winning for white ilysm
already very very unpleasant for black
to face
therefore if not Bishop e5 but 95 then
this will this is Sammy that dinkler
might have missed because now be 593
looks just week for black but there is
brilliant move King f1 and after Bishop
takes c3 Knight Texas Rangers wins
so this position so
that being said I think be free was
still giving a different big advantage
but Bishop b2 was understandably the
most human reply that and it's hard to
judge about that available play Bishop
to c5 takes takes and here I have really
really hard time understanding what
Fabian had in mind after age six with
age six because I understand that he
maybe didn't wanted to stop queen g5
Queen d2
draw arrows green truck went to
stabilizing the center bringing Queen
back and basically being two pawns up
for nothing but H six is a move that is
sort of like this feels wrong like you
want normally you should just play very
very actively being two pawns down and
trying to find concrete ways to deal
with opponents material advantage and
try to create some sort of muddy the
waters and we've moved like h6 you are
not doing that it's just kind of like
random move that gives white time and
time interest everything to stabilize
the position and just you know be mad
some something up like in here two pawns
up so in my opinion the correct move was
rupee five basically hitting the Queen
it will be the loop that will be the
first one that comes to my mind I'm sure
it was the same happened the same
happened to Fabiana that he was
considered at first but he's must he
must have not liked something I know
what
because Queen after Queen fake Queen
before it just hits on b2 and suddenly
there are ideas of night first of all
white is forced to defend passively
let's say Ruby one or okay two and white
black has ideas of 9h 598 night of four
maybe don't have five with very very
good compensation opinions let's for
instance rugby one by the for hitting
the Queen Queen g3 at age five Queen
back
f5
and this looks completely unclear Black
has certainly enough compensation for
the two pawns White's King is on the
phone come in danger in my opinion is
just very very unclear position but I
like blacks chances I really really like
backs trances because of the bad King on
f1 and the position being getting opened
F takes e4 is coming maybe ok Faden all
activity of black pieces is just very
very powerful in my pian but he didn't
do it but let's come back because after
h6 yes he wants to prevent Queen g5
rookie five stops you know I mean kicks
the Queen out Queen each frequent before
but we may ask why not Queen before
immediately because also he don't be too
similar I seems like it seems that we
can transpose to the same thing because
Ruby one would be five Queen h3 at the
same lines follow but there is
significant difference because there is
move like 25 right now and with rook
only five this was not possible because
we immediately kick the Queen out and
after Queen B to Queen comes back to c1
and suddenly what is just much better
simply because the Queen came back and
stabilizing the position and there is
not enough compensation here for for
black so this is very important that we
don't defend like rugby 1 but we defend
actively 25 bringing the Queen back
activating the the worst piece in the
position to Queen B - Queen c1 and
stabilizing the possible izing in the
center sort of and improve the Queen so
that being said h6 was a terrible move
in my opinion and here which if free
would have basically been very
unpleasant to face because right now a 4
square is covered there are ideas of Kim
G 2 and bring the from each one also may
be ideas of Queen h3 Queen G 2 queen of
2 because H 6 covers g5 but like with G
3 maybe we can improve the Queen in
other with in other Road let's say King
Queen each frequency to Queen f2 for
instance I can analyze Queen before
obi-wan
and I couldn't find any idea here for
for black that would have been
satisfactory let's say okay see maybe
King g2 also like it's hard to react
here with with with black my opinion so
this will be very strong he played rock
d1 which is a little bit inaccurate
because right now if a bellhop had
played a six with idea next b5 it opens
position even more opens the a and B
files and the idea is simply to just get
to White's King and is the most an
aggressive approach here because by b5
we thousand before and a six
Fabian played later later in the game
but it was already too late
unfortunately for him
so quinby's keep a Queen b6 when before
is met by some Europe d2 came over no no
conversation anymore but after a six
let's say G freebie five takes takes 90
X b5 I analyzed some lines like 97 for
instance King Queen a for Knight takes
d5 and this looks this is too huge mass
simply again what has to take probably
on d5 and try to sort of psalm make this
position solid but it's definitely
definitely unclear and anything can
happen basically so this was the best
chance here already for Fabian on
mapping to play six b5 because after
Queen b6 what he did
Rudi to Queenie free okay it seems like
it's forceful because a tax on b2 right
now attacks on d2 but with it doesn't
recreate any real friends because just
kind of like attacking here attacking
there but doesn't really lead anywhere
let's say a six he played yes he's
trying to play b5 but he could have done
much earlier and this was before white
already improved the rook and had right
now had time to bring a queen back
Quinn G free before 9123
just robbed the two Queen a for Fabian
regained one of the pause but after
Queen f2
why it finally stabilized the position
and this is just game over unfortunately
because the queen is coming to the game
to the two most likely before a king is
just stabilized a king is there right
now safe
there is no any counter play and in my
opinion just came over this proposed
formation a 45
not only is very strong but also
controls the vast majority of center and
after King Queen default setting of two
guru comes to the game back to the game
with rookie one King comes back to g1
it's simply that looks like just game
over
and because it's hard to basically stop
whoa sponsors was 93 no the five
possible possible ideas possible Bishop
c4 maybe these things eventually I don't
see anything else black can do here in
order to save this and so let's just see
how the game and that Queen d7 G free
where they are Kim G - obviously Queen
h3 just kim ji-won nothing wrong with
this a 524 threatening 9f - and Kim G -
right h5 trying to muddy the waters was
already it doesn't work anymore
I'd have to Queen d7 King okay it's not
like into a for hitting on h5 and right
now the only practical chance is just to
give the piece but this terrain not
working takes takes king of 126 rock g1
bringing the look to the game right now
King on the vines perfectly safe also is
the piece only for a pawn so it's not
enough f6 which should be five rupees
seven and the rest is just occupied be
free but very nice move technical move
just to prevent a fall in any case and
move number 40 so if he was in time
Trebek he's not in trouble anymore time
trouble anymore and sisters really nice
technique in the end throws just
zero-gravity rook to c2
Queenie freaked and g5 h 4f so 97 trying
to bring the 95 but doesn't rework
rook takes f6 just grabbing you in this
pawn rook a 547 and Bishop c6
this is just completely lost position
unfortunately for
his fans to rugby eight engaged seven
Queens Quincy Toby 75 this just this
just came over so yeah hopefully Fabiano
can strike back he played very very
entertaining trust very interesting
opening and for all of us it's a Lewis
let's hope he comes back with the next
win tomorrow but yeah this game in this
game he definitely employed very
interesting an opening idea only thing
that here I'm not sure about this 96
move my truck see probably in my opinion
is better and then he just messed messed
up unfortunately with this Bishop c5 I
mean this was quite but hidden hidden
play Luke e5 Queen before which would
have led to very unclear position and
possibly we have given him just even to
win the game because as I looked
dinkler had here like 20 minutes I've
happen heard like 1 hour 10 maybe or $15
you remember so if this happen in the
game Fabian oh I think we have had great
chances to win this but unfortunately he
didn't go for this and he had to face at
the feed in this game unfortunately so
hopefully he gets tracked back tomorrow
and the tournament is long so for all of
us in salute
we believe that he will come back and he
will face a Magnus Carson in December or
November in the of the year whenever
that match will be hopefully can he can
do this but for now I'm president gave
for him and hopefully he can recover
you
[Music]
you